I'm suture through Sebastian and this is
going to be my new magnet lab at the
University of Cambridge so what my
research is about is looking at
complicated materials under very extreme
conditions with the aim of creating new
quantum effects that emerge from
trillions of electrons so I put on very
high magnetic fields high pressures and
very low temperatures to bring the
material into this special quantum state
so this lab is something I've specially
designed I've been designing it for
quite a while now to provide specific
conditions such that a very high field
magnet reaching 21 Tesla's and going
down to very very low temperatures less
than 10 milli Kelvin which is less than
minus 272 degrees Celsius
this very special high field magnet and
low-temperature refrigerator we're going
to put crystals of these special
materials into this magnet which should
be installed within the next few months
and create just Sapir these conditions
that you only find in very few places in
the world such that we can create
amazing physics which revolutionize our
understanding of materials beyond
anything we know already